- [Narrator] Follow this simple technique.
Find a quiet place,
visualize your goal and
remember that you are amazing.
- You said you heard screaming?
- Yes, angry, taunting.
I just want a quiet house.
(scream)
- You hear that?
- Something's here.
- What if I have a bad dream?
(scream)
What if I dream that you send
us away into the dark and we
get hurt.
How I can't stand it
anymore and I have to die.
And time on a silver table,
with my jaw wired shut.
- (sobs) Mommy?
- Would you wake us up
from a dream like that?
- Get out from under there.
- I'm not under your bed,
I'm inside of your head.
(scream)
- [Demonic Voice] I could punish you.
- And I always keep my promises.
(distant child laughs)
(loud scream)
(scream)
- I hope there is no God.
(bones crunching)
Because if there is no heaven.
(rats squeaking)
There is no hell.
- Most people don't know you,
they don't see the evil
and the ugly in your heart.
(siren wailing)
- It's the end of the world.
- Maybe it's time to eat somebody.
- The census taker once tried to test me,
I ate his liver with some
flava beans and a nice Chianti.
(sucking in breath)
- It rubs the lotion on its skin
or else it gets the hose again.
- They're probably watching me,
well let them,
let them see what kind of a person I am.
I hope they are watching
(scream and slashing)
they'll see,
they'll see and they'll
know and they'll say,
"well she wouldn't even harm a fly."
(scream)
- I think my mask of
sanity is about to slim.
- [Female] Here we go now.
- We're not through yet.
Did you know I'm utterly insane?
(chainsaw revving)
- Paul? (screaming)
(banging)
- I have to kill a lot of people.
(smashing glass)
(scream)
- They always seat it like that in,
ah, chapter wise.
- But not you,
not with my misery.
(bone crunches and scream)
Misery was buried in the
ground at the end Paul,
so you'll have to start there.
No, not my misery.
God, I love you.
- I bet you think your husband
will be back any minute.
- Not like this,
I'm serious, stop.
Gerald?
Somebody, help.
- Try to call for help,
there's no one for miles.
(screams no)
- What were you doing last night?
- What real evidence have we got?
Nothing.
(man yells)
(shotgun loading)
- Everything I did here,
I did to protect us.
- Nearly enough.
(screams)
- Wait here.
- I don't think no one's on the horizon.
- These people,
they're blasphemous.
A cult, a disease.
- This island,
it's our paradise.
- You shall be cleansed according
to the Edith of this land.
(screams)
Let us begin.
(lightning)
- It's just a dream,
you're dreaming.
(rats squealing)
- We're not kids anymore.
I mean what did you think,
we're just going to sit
in our basement all day?
- It's important to me that you feel safe,
like this can still be your home
- Can you describe its form?
(distant screaming)
- No
extend its drawing , I think
my boundaries getting bigger,
its expanding .
- Anything interesting in there?
- No
- Ryan !
(Gun shots)
Shivers!
- Oh my God ..
- What are you looking at?
What do you see?
(Tires screeching )
What is wrong with you?
Please stop it!
(white noise)
Were going on the trip now
, its going to be ruff.
Hold on!
But under no circumstance
are you allowed to take
off your blindfold.
- Do you hear that?
- Please don't take my children !
- Somethings not right about this ,
I think we should head back to the road.
(audio distorted)
(screaming)
- What do you mean its happening again?
- You guys gotta see this ,
or her.
She's coming back .
- If you kill me now ,
the world as you know it
will end .
(car collision )
(up beat heavy rock music)